bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france aura tout d'abord parler
des points positifs tous les partis
seront représentés aujourd'hui à la
réunion c'est déjà un bon signal c'est
bon dans la mesure où ça contraste avec
l'émiettement des candidatures pour
l'heure à la présidentielle c'est un bon
signe mentionnons néanmoins que jean luc
mélenchon est pour la france un soumises
et fabien roussel pour le parti
communiste ne sont pas représentés
directement pardon ne viennent pas y
deviennent pas personnellement ils sont
représentés si j'insiste sur cette
dimension c'est qu'évidemment nous
présidentielle c'est pas une mini sipan
ces pannes régionales c'est pas une
départementale c'est pas une européenne
c'est la rencontre entre un homme projet
et puis le pays
évidemment orienté différemment selon
que l'on est de droite de gauche alors
candidature unique de la gauche est ce
que vraiment c'est possible quand on
connaît toutes les candidatures encore
en ont déclaré qu'ils ne sauraient
tarder et celles qui le sont déjà
je pense qu'il faut d'abord passer un
peu de temps sur le diagnostic nana10
comme politologue et ayant travaillé
lors de quatre présidentielle pour seize
candidats différents confidentiellement
la division d'un camp n'est pas la cause
des problèmes
la division d'un convient de ce que ces
candidats se sont éloignés une sujet du
pays et des fondamentaux du pays à un
moment donné en un mot les problèmes de
la gauche ne viennent pas de cette
division
le problème de la gauche vient de ce que
c'est sensibilité n'ont pas compris la
même période n'ont pas contrer les
sujets du moment
non pas contre et l'articulation
notamment entre d'accession nationale et
la question sociale
la question de l'arrêt
mais l'articulation entre l'identité et
les rapports sociaux
bref ce sont des problèmes de fond
auxquels sont confrontés les
sensibilités de gauche dont il s'agit d'
art et non pas en soi de problèmes de
division 2 personnes la gauche veut
contrer en éventuel annuel à un
maquereau le pen certains disent que
finalement c'est la seule chose sur
laquelle elles s'accordent comment
appréciez-vous ses propos d'abord je
pense qu'il est faux pour deux raisons
le premier c'est que quand règne
présidentielle pour l'emporter
on ne peut pas se contenter de dire
essentiellement on va contre on y va
contre un adversaire va outre à duel mc
on le paie même si pour les deux tiers
des français cette hypothèse ce serait
un satisfaisant si on va une
présidentielle c'est qu'on a quelque
chose à dire sur le fond non pas des
autres c'est pas bien c'est dangereux
séné mise et nous mêmes on a compris les
preuves du pays on a la capacité de le
résoudre via les primes du peuple
français ou le problème de la nation
donc voilà la première l'erreur danette
la seconde erreur d analyse c'est que
pour l'heure aucun candidat au second
tour de la présidentielle n'est en
mesure de battre marine le pen
ça veut dire que marine le pen depuis la
dernière présidentielle a tiré un
certain nombre de leçons a fait muter le
rassemblement national et que d'agos
depuis maintenant de nombreuses années à
un problème parce qu'à mon avis elle n'a
pas les bons outils
en tout cas je parle de cette gauche-là
fait gauche fut aussi entre
néolibéralisme et multiculturalisme
mon analyse c'est que au fond la gauche
républicaine a été mise de côté parce
que la gauche s'est éloigné des
catégories populaires
et que donc ce que représente la gauche
en ce moment on l'a vu dans les exemples
récents à universités notamment dans
certaines mairies europe ecologie les
verts ce que représente la gauche en ce
moment c'est tellement éloignés des
fondamentaux du pays en termes nationale
en termes républicain en terme de
laïcité qu'au fond d'elle même elle se
marginaliser elle n'apparait même plus
face à marine le pen comme étant un
rempart nécessaires pour parer du parti
europe écologie et les verts un
qu'annoncé il ya quelques jours elle
avait organisé une primaire les verts
dans les scores aux européennes et aux
municipales n'est pas à négliger
est ce que ça peut être une raison pour
ce parti des six mais qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à leur tour
écoutez ça fait longtemps que j'ai
commencé à travailler pour les
écologistes nous entoure et jetés en
1989 donc c'est ce n'est pas nouveau
qu'il y ait des interrogations sur
est-ce qu'on peut transformer les bons
scores aux européennes et aux
municipales aux présidentielles la
présidentielle c'est la question de la
capacité d'un candidat à portée du
commun au travers d'une orientation au
travers d'un projet mais dans une
relation un peu verticale avec le pays
or ce que sont les cadres et
sympathisants écologistes et le noyau
dur de son électorat n'est véritablement
pas adaptée à une présidentielle
parmi les écologistes clairement yannick
jadot est selon moi celui qui est le
plus adapté à ce qu'est une
présidentielle mais vous me verrez lors
de la primaire et leur animal parce que
ce déplacement à la primaire le noyau
dur d'europe écologie les verts
j'ai plus gauchiste l'écologiste et qui
ne voient finalement passé antisystème
yannick jadot justement cette réunion
c'est à son initiative à ce que c'est
une façon pour lui de tirer les parle du
feu c'est une façon pour lui de se
positionner comme étant rassemble le
responsable partant du fait que la tri
salutaire montre l'importance de la
question écologique que ça soit le
réchauffement climatique la biodiversité
et le rapport au fond à la nature donc
il ya bien une question écologique
centrale le problème c'est la
représentation de ça donc il ya deux
jadot il c'est de tenir il décolle et
unitaire et a touché celle de j call au
juste le fait d'être unitaire c'est une
sorte de mantra qui à mon avis est
illusoire car seul trait validé cioni de
foot et en même temps de lire parce que
sa campagne européenne a été très bonne
en tout cas bonne
c'est une façon de lire celui peut
transformer l'essai du régional stéphane
rozès merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur arte france se rappelle
que vous êtes politologue merci à vous